NASA's first planetary defense operation
has struck a space Rock that's orbiting
an asteroid millions of kilometers from
Earth the goal was to nudge the little
Moon into a new orbit scientists were
testing whether it's possible to deflect
an asteroid on collision course with our
planet
oh my gosh oh wow awaiting visual
confirmation a direct hit millions of
kilometers from Earth
the world's first ever planetary defense
Mission a success that is far from a
coincidence
we are so excited
uh you know we've worked on this mission
for at least seven years now and uh it's
been a work of over a thousand people
um definitely as we were getting close
to the asteroid there was a lot of Ed
said Joy I say both Terror and joy at
the same time because we we saw that we
were going to impact the idea behind dot
the double asteroid redirection test was
to launch a small spacecraft toward the
space rock smash into it at high speed
and alter its course
this inaugural planetary defense test
mission marks a major moment in human
history for the first time ever we will
measurably change the orbit of a
Celestial body in the universe doing so
has clear benefits in ensuring
Humanity's ability to deflect a
potential threatening asteroid in the
future
NASA proved it could hit a small object
in space
a follow-up Mission will check up on the
target Rock in four years to see how
much its orbit has changed
but first it is time for celebrations
now let's go straight to Dr Thomas
sabukin a head of science at Nasa in
Washington DC first of all
congratulations your spacecraft has
struck its Target but did it actually
manage to throw the rock off course
well thanks so much we're extremely
proud of the team that got us there and
uh and I want to tell you what we've
I've been looking at all day here is
data from spacecraft both uh Alicia Cuba
a small spacecraft that we actually
released from dark before the impact and
and went and flew by uh three minutes
later but also from ground-based
Observatory so we know the impact was
big and violent it was observable from
the ground and it's the matter of
physics that it will have uh you know
moved the rock but we need to measure it
and that will take a few weeks to really
measure the orbit that's at 12 hour
orbit uh that the uh the you know the
the small Moon of this asteroid has that
we had and that will uh hopefully uh
have moved by two to three minutes or
guessing from what we're observing
perhaps even more
now you call this a test of the
planetary defense system what does that
entail
well so the fact that we get hit by
rocks from space over the history of the
earth is is well you know understood now
look at the moon it's scarred with
impacts the Earth also is scarred with
impact and of course it has a had major
major uh kind of consequences for life
on Earth dinosaurs are no longer with us
for example as a result of one of those
impacts and so what we're really trying
to do is in the Arsenal of kind of uh
overall tools that we have to protect
lives on Earth we want to add a tool
that could help us in in case a
threatening asteroid like did would show
up I want to tell you that this moment
in time we don't have one that we're
aware of that could uh hit uh within the
next hundred years so we're really
trying to get a tool that we could use
in case we found one now what about the
cost of this Mission and all that work
involves you think it's Justified
oh absolutely it's Justified I think
when it comes to protecting life on
Earth uh it kind of the cost that we're
putting into these space assets is very
much uh Justified I want to tell you
right now we have a hurricane and uh
South uh Florida that is over Cuba and
getting in there most of the forecasts
come from space assets that uh that we
did uh you know right now I have made in
the past kind of spacecraft that I've
helped launch uh we've built uh here at
Nasa and and uh and in the same way a
planetary uh defense uh is really kind
of in a more longer term uh scale really
helping protecting lives on Earth so uh
it's absolutely Justified
now the dark mission is just the latest
of several NASA projects dealing with
asteroids why are you focusing on these
celestial bodies
asteroids are really interesting for us
because they're kind of Messengers from
the time past or if you want uh kind of
really about a chapter in our own
history the history of the solar system
asteroids form early on kind of as
planets form uh and uh and kind of uh
looking at these primordial uh materials
these asteroids and bringing the samples
back which is what we're doing with uh
osiris-rex next year we're going to drop
it into a Utah test range the sample
that we picked up in 2020 but also
exploring families of asteroids we've
never seen such as what Lucy is doing is
really learning about our own past
learning about the history of the solar
system and then these asteroids
sometimes are threats which is why we
did that Dart
it's all very exciting Dr Thomas the
book in there head of science at Nasa in
Washington DC thanks for joining us here
on DW news
thank you so much